[Musique]
8h30 début de cette deuxième journée de
visite des associations de protection de
l'enfance attendait le secrétaire d'état
un moment d'échangés important car plus
de 6000 jeunes bénéficient d'un
dispositif d'accompagnement à la réunion
un peu plus tard c'était la visite de la
crèche marilou à s'attendre et un cas
concret d'accompagnement de la petite
enfance
tout comme cette crèche itinérante pour
les enfants des écarts de lille mais
pour pouvoir justement promouvoir le
bien-être de l'enfant des parents mais
offrir aussi un mode de garde pour les
parents habitant dans les écarts des
saladiers nous avons fait le choix
effectivement d'avoir de vrais
instruments pour les familles et pour
pour les enfants pour leur faire
découvrir dans la qualité déjà la
rencontre des parents d'enfants porteurs
de handicap se fera à huis clos avant la
signature d'une convention de mise en
place du projet pôle ressources et
handicap
certains enfants aujourd'hui n'ont pas
accès à des structures d'accueil parce
que les conditions matérielles peuvent
ne pas suffire parce que en termes de
personnel il faut du personnel formé et
qui puisse être sensibilisés aux
différentes formes de handicap
donc ce pôle de ressources a vocation à
accompagner la formation à renforcer les
compétences des professionnels de la
petite enfance
donc c'est un besoin identifié sur
l'ensemble du territoire la question du
handicap puisque nous parlons de sa est
une compétence départementale mail et à
d'ores et déjà mis de l'argent dans le
cadre de la stratégie de prévention et
protection de l'enfance qui a fait
l'objet d'une signature hier avec le
président du conseil départemental mais
où l'état arrive avec 4,6 millions
d'euros pour la protection de l'enfance
dans son ensemble mais avec des projets
qui porte spécifiquement sur le handicap
j'ai eu l'occasion dé évoqué et puis
face à cela le département met de
l'argent supplémentaire et
l'investissement de l'état ses 4,6
millions d'euros c'est cette année mais
ça sera aussi l'année prochaine et
l'année suivante faciliter la vie des
enfants et de leurs parents pour une
meilleure équité
reste l'espoir de cette matinée de
visite l'après midi sera marquée par la
visite de l'ue daf une association de
plus de 45 ans qui s'occupe des familles
dans toute leur diversité
comme ici des réunions d'information des
parents qui viennent de se séparer et
doivent construire demain
dans l'espace rencontre avec ces filtres
des volumes comme vous voyez mais bien
sûr le qu'ovide obligeant dû prendre des
précautions
enfin d'autres parents sylvie et
alexandre sont venus apporter leur
témoignage celui d'un accompagnement
important à ce moment de leur vie et
j'ai vécu dans une situation où pendant
deux ans j'ai pas vu mon fils on était
des barrages tout ça et du coup ben la
médiation il a aidé beaucoup et a évolué
les choses et aussi que ben voilà
octobre j'ai pu voir mon fils j'ai passé
des bons moments avec lui cette
convention est nécessaire parce qu'on va
lancer aujourd'hui un appel à projets
pour créer deux espaces de rencontres
complémentaires et garantir une équité
d'intervention sur l'ensemble du
territoire de la réunion on voit
malheureusement croître une demande
importante des familles notamment en
situation de rupture notamment en
situation de divorce qui ont besoin
d'avoir cette médiation familiale
une journée de visite qui s'est conclue
par la découverte des ateliers pour les
nouveaux papas organisé par la caf de
beauséjour
[Musique]